ce nouveau numéro de reporter nous
conduit aujourd'hui en Amérique centrale
depuis 8 mois le Salvador est sous
régime de l'état d'exception le
président du pays a déclaré une guerre
totale au gang ultra-violent et pour
cela il a suspendu les garanties
constitutionnelles les arrestations de
masse se multiplient près de 60 000 en 8
mois des milliers de délinquants sont
désormais en prison mais pas seulement
Laurence cuvilliers correspondante de
France 24 dans la région va découvrir
avec vous l'ampleur de cette répression
conduite par le président naïb boukélé
qui a beaucoup de supporters dans la
population même si ces méthodes
expéditives conduisent aussi des
innocents derrière les barreaux Laurence
oui tout à fait parce que sous l'état
d'exception la police peut arrêter
n'importe qui sur simple soupçon par
exemple sur la dénonciation malveillante
d'un voisin ou si la personne n'a pas
ses papiers d'identité sur elle et
surtout des quotas d'arrestation ont été
établis pour chaque commissariat pour
faire du chiffre et montrer l'efficacité
de cette politique résultat probablement
des milliers d'innocents en prison mais
derrière ce chiffre ce sont des familles
rester sans revenu des familles
stigmatisées alors que le gouvernement
de n'ayez boukélé continue de marteler
que toutes les personnes arrêtées sont
des terroristes et donc des tensions
économiques et sociales qui perdureront
sans doute bien au-delà de cet état
d'exception alors on va découvrir votre
reportage Salvador un autocrate contre
les gangs reportage signalons cuvilliers
avec Matthieu commun
[Musique]
21h à Sainte Salvador devant elle
pénalito la petite prison
ces familles attendent la libération
d'un de leurs proches certaines n'ont
pas quitté ce trottoir depuis plusieurs
semaines
pendu au lèvres de l'agent qui prononce
quelques noms chaque soir
quelques instants plus tard
ce soir là deux hommes sont libérés
[Musique]
on sait que d'un jour à l'autre on
pourrait vivre ça nous aussi
c'est triste pour nous on voit ce qui se
passe ici mais nous on reste sans
nouvelles de nos enfants qui sont de
l'autre côté
tous ces gens nous ont demandé de
masquer leur visage par peur de la
répression
au Salvador en ce moment plus d'une
personne sur 100 est en prison
thomasa et son mari eux ont tenu à
témoigner un visage découvert
depuis ses 18 ans il a toujours
travaillé ça c'était son uniforme
leur fils rouelle Alejandro travaillait
pour une agence de télécommunication il
a été capturé le 6 juin alors qu'il
installait des câbles avec son
entreprise son casier judiciaire était
vierges
[Musique]
l'avocat nous a juste dit qu'il fallait
attendre
il va rester 6 mois en prison préventive
pendant qu'ils font leur enquête
mais le cas par cas n'existe plus lors
de la journée d'audience de rohelle à
huis clos 162 dossiers étaient examinés
du motif de la détention ni des charges
qui pèsent contre lui on suppose que
c'est à cause de ses tatouages
les tatouages une preuve à charge au
Salvador
car depuis la fin de la guerre civile en
1992 un autre mâle s'est emparé du pays
les Marras
des gangs ultra-violents qui terrorisent
la population
de grandes marasses la MS et la 18 se
livrent une guerre pour le contrôle des
quartiers il porte leur appartenance à
ses groupes jusque sur leur visage
ce sont des marasses qui ont enlevé la
petite sœur de Roel Ketty en 2016 elle
est portée disparue depuis elenquête n'a
jamais avancé rohelle lui ne portait que
des tatouages artistiques
lui il s'était tatoué le nom de sa mère
sur l'avant-bras et ça c'est une
palmeraie où il s'est représenté tenant
ses enfants par la main
beaucoup de gens disent c'est super ce
que fait le président
54 000 détenus en six mois ont tassé
dans des prisons déjà surchargées les
familles n'ont aucun droit de visite
mais elles doivent assurer
l'approvisionnement des tenues blanches
du papier toilette des aliments et
jusqu'aux produits d'entretien
mais le pire c'est de ne pas savoir
comment il va
c'est terrible
ce que beaucoup ont vécu ces derniers
mois
on leur a dit que leur fils était mort
et on leur a rendu dans un sac mortuaire
les associations de défense des droits
humains sont prises dans un raz-de-marée
de plainte pour détention arbitraires ou
d'essai inexpliquées dans les prisons
bonjour madame Luce je m'appelle Mario
sorto je suis avocat et notaire quel âge
avait Miguel il allait avoir 37 ans ils
l'ont capturé le 6 avril
le 6 avril 2022
à quelle heure l'ont-ils capturé
[Musique]
il était ouvrier dans la construction
même quand il n'avait pas de travail il
apportait un peu d'argent 5 ou 10
dollars
il m'a jetait un peu de café du savon du
produit de vaisselle
c'était un bon fils
il avait des problèmes de pression
artérielle sa femme dit que quand ils
l'ont arrêté il sait tout de suite senti
très mal
au centre de détention ne vous ont donné
aucune information
non il nous disait que c'était interdit
que sur ordre du président il ne pouvait
absolument rien dire sur ce qui se
passait à l'intérieur
la semaine d'après je suis retournée
devant la prison je ne suis pas allé
travailler j'avais juste besoin de me
sentir plus proche de lui mais il
n'était plus là
il était déjà à la morgue
donc il est mort le 4 mai et vous avez
été prévenu le 15 mai presque 11 jours
ce sont passés avant que vous soyez
informés
ni la prison ni la morgue qui vous a
appelé mais les pompes funèbres
comme le fils de Luz des dizaines de
détenus sont morts dans des
circonstances inexpliquées et sans
attention médicale
le président Nailly boukélé fait de la
haine contre ses détenus le cheval de
bataille de sa popularité
toutes les cellules seront bouclées 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 personne
ne sortira même dans la cour il ne
verront pas la lumière du jour
depuis 5 ans la criminalité a enfin
commencé à baisser mais les autorités
estiment qu'il y aurait dans le pays 70
000 membres de gangs un tatouage des
lettres MS ou du chiffre 18 comme sur ce
jeune homme et la promesse d'une longue
peine de prison
nous allons l'emmener au commissariat de
Soyapango nous allons consulter nos
fichiers pour vérifier si les fichiers
comme membres de gang actif il est
possible qu'il soit amené en détention
pour le délit d'association de
malfaiteurs
nous respectons l'autorité le
gouvernement
nous bénissons le gouvernement vous êtes
dans le droit chemin et nous nous
restons soumis à Dieu
lui c'est mon fils et lui c'est un
employé qui fait partie comme moi de
l'église évangélique apostolique
ils viennent de procéder à l'arrestation
de votre fils
je ne peux pas vous le dire c'est Dieu
qui aura le dernier mot
l'état d'exception en vigueur depuis fin
mars permettent à la police de ne pas
informer les suspects du motif de leur
arrestation
en vérité ce qui vient de se passer
c'est Dieu qui manifeste sa volonté vous
saviez que votre fils était membre d'un
gang il a été pendant quelques années
mais plus maintenant il est désormais
entre les mains de Dieu
simple soupçon dénonciation d'un voisin
on arrête d'abord on enquête ensuite
cette maison
sortez les mains derrière la tête
on voit qu'il boit c'est plein de
bouteilles ici alors dites moi c'est
quoi son vrai travail mais je viens de
vous expliquer que qui a payé tout ça
comme je vous le disais il vient de
perdre son travail mais il travaillait
honnêtement et tout ça je l'ai acheté
avec l'argent que m'envoie le père de ma
fille vous avez des proches membres de
gangs non comme je lui ai expliqué
et votre frère qui a été arrêté mais il
ne fait pas partie d'un gang mais il a
pourtant été arrêté sous le régime
d'exception oui mais ok et donc oui il a
été arrêté mais pas pour appartenir un
gang
un fouillant dans le téléphone de la
femme du jeune homme le policier tombe
sur une photo compromettante
il ne nous la montrera pas mais il
affirme qu'elle lui fait un signe de
main distinctif des Maras
les deux personnes sont finalement
arrêtées un grand ménage qui soulage
l'immense majorité des Salvadoriens mais
qui emporte tout sur son passage
Ernesto fait partie des 15000
fonctionnaires récemment démis de leur
fonction il a vécu les deux premiers
mois de l'état d'exception dans la
police
d'arrestation du petit commissariat de
quartier au plus grandes unités de
police on avait tous des objectifs à
atteindre
la première c'était quand mercredi
dernier nous avons arrêté 1090 membres
de gangs en un seul jour si maintenant
ils sont en fuite ils se cachent comme
des rats je ne veux pas offenser les
rats mais littéralement ils vont se
cacher dans des trous dans la terre et
la terre
d'abord on avait eu ça d'un bon œil
parce qu'avant les policiers étaient
piés pour liés pour agir efficacement
contre les marasses
mais on a vite vu que ça tournait mal il
fallait qu'on arrête n'importe qui pour
atteindre l'objectif et c'est là qu'on
commençait les injustices on a arrêté
beaucoup de personnes qui n'avaient rien
à voir avec les gangs et bien sûr
pendant ce temps les marins sont fait
tout ce qu'il fallait pour fuir aller se
réfugier dans les campagnes quitter le
pays
on viole les droits humains
les organismes internationaux de défense
du crime
ils disent qu'ils défendent les droits
humains c'est les foutaises
quelle famille dans notre pays n'a pas
une histoire terrifiante à raconter
sur ce que les gangs ont fait subir
[Musique]
rencontre des jeunesse de Noé va sidéas
le parti du président n'ayez boukélé
le président boukélé est un exemple pour
tous les jeunes Salvadoriens beaucoup de
jeunes leaders sont inspirés par son
projet politique et par le président le
plus jeune d'Amérique latine qui
continuera à décrire l'histoire en 2024
l'année de la prochaine élection
présidentielle la Constitution
salvadorienne interdit formellement le
renouvellement du mandat mais n'ayez
boucle a décidé de passer outre
nous avons vu beaucoup de gens qui
vivent dans la peur des gens qui ont
peur de s'exprimer parce qu'ils
craignent que la police viennent les
arrêter pour avoir critiqué le
gouvernement qu'en pensez-vous
vous voulez dire actuellement oui
beaucoup de gens ont peur de parler
parce qu'ils ont peur des détentions
arbitraires
et que pardon pardon mais en ce moment
non
masse détresse
pour des tensions arbitraires plus de 80
détenus sont morts dans des
circonstances troubles il y a beaucoup
de violations des droits humains depuis
le début de l'état d'exception
de l'intestination
notre président a été très clair dans
son discours aux Nations Unies et
nous sommes en Italie et souverain
et tout commentaire négatif venant d'un
autre pays ou d'une institution
étrangère me paraît vraiment déplacé
[Musique]
l'état d'exception est fait pour
répondre à une urgence sécurité mais
après six mois il s'est installé dans la
durée au Salvador pour certains il
libère le pays des gangs pour d'autres
il le soumettent à une autre violence
celle des dérives autoritaires de l'État
[Musique]
et on retrouve Laurence cuvilliers
correspondante de France 24 Laurence le
président nahibou kele est aujourd'hui
très braqué contre les ONG de défense
des droits de l'homme et contre la
presse est-ce que vous l'avez senti sur
le terrain pendant ce reportage oui tout
à fait c'est un discours qui s'est
révélé d'ailleurs très efficace au
Salvador un discours dans lequel Nagui
boukélé veut défendre par tous les
moyens une population vulnérable face
aux marins une population qui
effectivement a été puisée par des
décennies de meurtre dans les mains
d'extorsion alors que selon lui l'ONU
les ONG et les associations des défenses
des droits de l'homme ne font que
défendre des terroristes et veulent
t'empêcher son gouvernement d'en finir
par la méthode forte avec le règne au
démarrage c'est un discours qui m'appel
depuis des mois je vous propose d'en
écouter ces paroles
il y a quelques jours
la direction des centres pénitenciers a
fait sortir les prisonniers
des pierres tombales des membres des
gangs mais bien sûr immédiatement des
organismes internationaux et de défense
des droits de l'homme sont montés au
créneau en demandant pourquoi en violet
les droits des membres des camps décédés
bon d'abord on interdit pas aux membres
des gangs d'avoir des tombes ce qu'on
interdit c'est que ces tombes portent la
mention Mara Salvatrucha ou Barrio
diessio
tout simplement parce que Salvador
depuis le vote de la loi sur la
proscription des gangs ses symboles sont
interdits
en ce moment en sauveur face à la
gangrène des marins il faut pas oublier
qu'il a par le passé négocié avec elle
et établi un pacte avec la maréchal va
trop de chat qui est la plus puissante
du pays impacte qui visait à faire
baisser les homicides en échange de
faveur pour les membres des marasses
emprisonnés et c'est précisément la
rupture de ce pacte qui a provoqué un
déchaînement de violence le week-end du
26 mars dernier et amené à la
déclaration de l'état d'exception qui
est encore en vigueur aujourd'hui merci
Laurence donc pour cette photographie du
Salvador et de cette guerre contre les
gangs c'est la fin de ce magazine merci
à vous de l'avoir suivi et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]